How do we understand the risk that is
posed to the cyber assets that we have?
So this is going to require that we
understand the risk to the online
information, and the systems where it is
stored, and how they're connected, and
who they can be accessed by,
and things like that.
So these kind of questions
are exactly what we call
developing a security mindset.
A security mindset is really
asking the kind of questions
that I was just talking about.
So if you say, well what exactly,
how do you define a security mindset?
You have to say, well,
who are the bad actors?
What can possibly they exploit?
What vulnerabilities do I have?
And if they are successful in
exploiting a vulnerability,
what is that attack going to be?
So in the security mindset,
the first thing we worry about
is what is the threat source.
In particular, who is the entity
that wants to do us harm?
So, there are obviously these
criminals who are in it for
the money, professional criminals
who want to profit from
the data that they can steal.
There's another sort of threat
source people worry about.
These are activists who use
the Internet, in particular, hacking.
That's why they're called hacktivists,
and they have some sort of an agenda.
People may agree with it,
or may not agree with it.
When you sort of think about Snowden,
well he had an agenda.
He didn't like certain things that
the US government was doing, and
that was the reason for him.
It wasn't that he was trying to profit
from the information that he took, but
the reason really was activism.
Finally, threats can
come from nation-states.
And countries are actually doing this,
they're doing it for
political advantage, they're doing
it for spying on each other.
So the risk comes from sort of
the threat source, sort of the entire
spectrum, from a set of group of
criminals all the way to nation-states.
So the threats are clearly very real.